so now that we've talked about shutdowns
let's talk about why we have them and
why we are not in a position to open in
any significant way we're not doing
enough testing some of the tests don't
have a quick enough turnaround time and
we don't have a proper contact tracing
infrastructure and I know that this may
be boring stuff but I think it's
important to go through so that it's not
a mystery to anybody we are not unable
to open because governors are
authoritarian dictators that that's not
why when we see other countries starting
to open up and yet here we have so many
health experts say we're just not
anywhere close to ready the reason is
that the Trump administration hasn't
built a proper testing system or a
proper contact tracing system despite
constantly bragging that we have the
best tests and the most tests and all of
this stuff so let's explore it why do we
need more tests to open we have about a
million official cases right now a
little more than that closing in on 1.1
million every antibody tests that's been
done so far suggests that the real rate
of cases is at least three times the
official rate maybe as many as 20 or 30
times the official rate so what that
means is we're only testing a fraction
of the people who have the virus this
means you have likely millions of people
who don't know that they have it who are
going around spreading it especially the
asymptomatic people if we were testing
at really high levels you could ensure
that everyone who has any symptoms that
minimum could get tested and know if
they have it
if the turnaround of the tests was
uniformly faster people could learn more
quickly that they have it and
immediately quarantine as opposed to
maybe quarantine II may be saying I
don't know that I have it I'm gonna keep
walking around and if you had proper
contact tracing infrastructure you could
immediately contact the individuals that
had been potentially exposed by every
new case and say hey your friend your
coworker or whatever has been exposed
has tested positive you now need to
isolate for 14 days this is what South
Korea did and they had their first case
on the same day that we did now what is
the truth about testing levels because
there's a lot of disinformation here
doctor foul she has said we need to be
testing at roughly three to four million
tests
per week to realistically think about
opening so in the last seven days we
have tested 1.5 million people that's an
average of 222 thousand people per day
this is better than early April no doubt
in the first seven days of April we
averaged a hundred and forty three
thousand tests a day in the last week
we've averaged two hundred and
twenty-two thousand s an improvement of
about fifty percent but it's been an
entire month they said by the end of
March we would have tested tens of
millions of people that date came and
went and we are still only testing about
two hundred and twenty thousand a day so
as a bare minimum as an absolute bare
minimum we have to test five hundred
thousand people per day reliably which
is more than twice where we are right
now there are public health experts who
say we really need a million tests a day
there is one model that says we need 20
million tests per day which is I mean
that's science fiction at this point
particularly until you have an antigen
test right now we have RNA tests until
you have antigen tests it would be very
difficult really impossible to test at
that level so instead of actually
increasing testing Donald Trump spends
this time bragging and lying even this
morning Donald Trump tweeted quote we
are doing far more and better testing
than any other country in the world and
yet the media does nothing but complain
no matter how good a job is done the
same as with the ventilators they will
never say we are doing a great job
they will only viciously gripe the
data's public if you look at the top
testing per capita the United States is
43rd in the world in testing per capita
were behind Belgium but we're ahead of
Belarus now some people say you can't
really compare the u.s. to the Faroe
Islands you have to eliminate the tiny
countries from that list well okay if
you concede that the u.s. as a country
is 27th in the world among reasonably
sized countries so we are nowhere near
the top the numbers are public if you're
out there complaining about my state
isn't open my governor
a dictator or whatever just look at
testing if Trump spent half the time
that he spends bragging about testing
actually working to increase tests we
could be testing 500,000 a day by now we
could be testing 750,000 a day by now
and we could be having more reasonable
conversations about actually opening up
this is why we are not ready to open in
any significant way at this point in
time let me know your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman our sponsor Nord VPN
is giving you 70% off a three-year plan
which is just a little over three bucks
a month and you will get an extra month
free when you go to Nord BPM comm slash
David Pakman or just go to their website
and use the coupon code David Pakman by
this point in time if you're not using a
VPN when you're on the internet you are
putting yourself at a huge disadvantage
Nord VPN keeps your IP address hidden
when you're browsing online keeps your
personal data safe from hackers prevents
websites from following you around the
internet and you can even use it on your
phone there are many different VPN
options out there but Nord VPN is the
one I trust because they don't log your
internet history they use military-grade
encryption and they encrypt your data
twice to double the anonymity Nord VPN
is giving you 70% off a three-year plan
that's just over three bucks a month
plus an extra month free when you go to
north VPN dot-com slash David Pakman
I've put a link right underneath the
video or just go to their website and
use the coupon code david pakman